[Music]
neuroscientist russ pauldrack is the
albert ray lang professor in the
department of psychology at stanford
university and the director of the
stanford center for reproducible
neuroscience through his research dr
pauldrack uses neuroimaging to
understand the brain system's underlying
decision making and executive function
he's also the author of the 2018 book
the new mind readers what neuroimaging
can and cannot reveal about our thoughts
joining him in conversation tonight is
fellow neuroscientist liz phelps the
pershing square professor of human
neuroscience in the department of
psychology at harvard university her
award-winning research lies at the
intersection of memory learning emotion
and decision making
tonight they will be discussing dr
pauldrack's latest book hard to break
hailed as authoritative brilliant and
entertaining the book not only details
the habits of individuals but also
discusses the massive societal habit
changes that'll be needed to address the
biggest challenges of our time
author and psychologist angela duckworth
praises the book writing russ paldrack
is the rare scientist who can push the
frontier of knowledge forward and also
reach back offer his hand and help the
rest of us catch up we're so pleased to
host them for this event tonight so
without further ado dr phelps and dr
pauldrack the digital podium is yours
thank you so much so it's um it's an
honor to be here and to host this
discussion
with my longtime colleague russ poldrack
um i'm just going to give go through a
series of questions uh for russ and hear
a little bit what he has to say and then
happy to take your questions at the end
so to start my first question for you
russ so i've known ross i should say
since he was a
we grad student um and that's that's you
know a little more than 20 years i'm not
going to say exactly how long because
it'll embarrass us both but
um but at that time even as a grad
student russ was doing some of the very
first studies looking at the relation
the the representation of habits and
habit learning in the human brain so
russ has been doing this his entire
career he is one of the world's experts
uh or the world expert on this topic in
terms of human brain and so the first
question i have for you russ is why did
you write this book now
what what what motivated you to finally
do this book that really has encapsulate
what you've been doing your entire
career
yeah yeah well first thanks for uh
thanks for doing this it's fun to have a
discussion about this with you um
it's an interesting question you know
it took me a long time to decide that i
could write a book at all
and um the the first book that i wrote
the new mind readers you know was i
wrote because i felt like i had a story
to tell and that i was the right person
to tell it and i kind of felt the same
way about this you know it's like this
is a
set of questions that i've been thinking
about for a long time and there's been
you know
i think the work that we did and that
others have done you know over the last
couple decades have made a lot of
progress and then there's particularly
been a lot of progress in the last few
years coming out of
uh some of the new techniques that
people have been developing in
neuroscience and um and it seemed like
the right time to write this book you
know there's there's lots of books out
about habits right and there's there's
lots of really good books but none of
them had really sort of um
gone into the depth about the
neuroscience of habits that i thought
was really necessary for someone to
really understand where they come from
so so who is this book for like when you
were writing the book who who in your
mind was the the reader of the book
um it's really for somebody who you know
is is not an expert in neuroscience but
knows you know knows a little bit and is
really interested in
sort of you know learning a lot more
about how these things works and isn't
afraid of you know some sort of
sophisticated
uh
science writing you know it definitely
you know i definitely try to keep it as
you know sort of accessible as possible
to people without deep expertise in
neuroscience but but i don't shy away
from you know going into a little bit of
detail when i think it's really
necessary to understand how these things
work so you know as a neuroscientist
when i was reading the book
you know even if i wasn't interested in
habits i would want to read it because
you do such a good job at explaining
some of these new complicated techniques
that are coming up particularly in the
animal work and so it's a student it's a
book i want my students to read you know
partially because it's great it's a
great book about the neuroscience of
habits but partially because you also
really do a good job at explaining the
neuroscience in a way that i think a
non-expert would understand um which
doesn't surprise me given your history
and
as in in studying brain imaging in the
human brain okay so i want to now start
with the basics
could you say could you define what is a
habit and what isn't a habit
yeah um so
you know there's there's sort of like a
there's there's a few ways to define
them right you know
uh sort of intuitively think we think of
habits as
sort of you know routines or things that
we sort of do automatically like you
know william james talked about habits
in you know when he wrote about them in
the 1800s about like you know all the
sort of the routines that we automate so
we don't have to think about them
because otherwise we would be spending
every moment thinking about like you
know when i get up in the morning having
to think about now i have to press the
button to turn on the coffee machine
which way do i move the lever on the
espresso machine you know all those
types of things that that sort of remain
the same in the world
in general and so you know
there's no need for us to sort of you
know continue to think about them each
time
so so that's one way to think about
habits is sort of like the routines that
we automate because um because we don't
need to think about them because the
world is remaining the same right and
there's it's important to keep in mind
that there's
one there's one set of things that don't
change in the world like think about
driving right the way that the pedals
work in your car generally don't change
but like the place you park in the
parking garage every day if you assuming
you don't have your own parking spot
that changes from day to day right and
one of the things you know you and i
both worked a long time ago on these
questions about you know the different
memory systems in the brain one of the
important things we've learned is that
the brain systems for habits
are distinct from the brain systems that
allow us to actually you know kind of
consciously remember
the events that happened right and we
that's sort of intuitive right we often
because we often have these slips where
like we can't remember if we locked the
door or not right because locking the
door becomes a habit and we just no
longer even generate a memory for it um
so that's that's one way to think about
habits another way is that that
scientists focus more on has to do with
um
sort of
how they're generated and why or why
they
why they sort of hang around um so think
about like why do we do things in
general when the first time we do think
we do something we do it because we have
a goal in mind right we like i go to the
refrigerator because i want because i'm
thirsty and i want something to drink
um we call that a goal-directed behavior
but over time if if something gets done
over and over again
um it can start to basically take on a
life of its own such that even if the
goal isn't important anymore
um
the the the organism that being me or a
rat or whoever else is being studied um
will still do the thing um so that it
becomes basically the goal doesn't
matter anymore and that that's important
for like why habits continue to hang
around right because when the goal
doesn't matter anymore even if the the
reward goes away you keep doing the
thing anyway
and what isn't a habit
what isn't a habit well we think
goal-directed behaviors in general like
things that we do in order to explicitly
achieve a goal
we think of generally are not habits
and that's at least for scientists
that's the big distinction that we make
um
now you know there's there's debates
about you know exactly where to draw
that line but that's kind of the big
difference is like when i when i do
something with intention with conscious
intention towards a goal that's what we
think of as not being a habit so every
day our actions are some combination of
the two exactly
so so you talk a lot about dopamine
so i just want to give you like an
opportunity to talk a little bit about
why dopamine's so important for habits
right then i'll ask you a few more
questions about that
von bell called dopamine the kim
kardashian of neurotransmitters
um
yeah so why is dopamine so important for
habits so you know dopamine everybody
thinks of dopamine as having something
to do with like pleasure or you know
reward and it it certainly is related
but you know what we've learned about
dopamine well dopamine is incredibly
complex right there's you know many
different types of dopamine receptors in
the brain and it does different things
in different parts of the brain but with
respect to habits the really important
um aspect of dopamine is that so when we
when we receive a reward
or when we encounter some thing in the
world that tells us we're going to get a
reward that causes the release of
dopamine
and um
there's
when we're going out you know through
the world kind of choosing what to do
one of the important ways that that
happens is in you know the connections
from our cerebral cortex down into our
basal ganglia
um end up sort of competing with one
another like you know let's say i want
to i come to a fork in the road i have
to decide do i go left or right there's
going to be one subset of neurons saying
go left there's going to be another
subset saying go right
one of them is going to win
and let's say that you know i then like
you know end up in a really great place
at the end of the road
that's going to
you know cause some dopamine to be
released
and one of the things that we know that
dopamine does in the basal ganglia is
when neurons are firing together at the
same time
and there's dopamine it causes those
connections to get stronger
and so that what that means is next time
those because the neurons with the
stronger connections have a
greater likelihood of winning that
competition and so you're more you're
going to be more likely to do the thing
this is sort of an explanation for
this you know there's this thing
psychologists called the law of effect
which is like you know one of the most
obvious laws ever was like if you if you
do something and it gives you good stuff
you're going to do it more often if you
do something and it gives you bad stuff
you're going to do it less often right
this
that action of dopamine provides an
explanation for that thing that we've
known forever about human behavior
so okay but you know you say it's not
all about pleasure right so
so what do people get wrong about
dopamine yeah so um
so
it's reasonable why people would think
it's about pleasure because um
you often the situations when dopamine
is being released are situations that
are related to things that people find
pleasurable but the distinction that one
that's really important to make
is
between and this comes from this was
really kind of developed by kent barrage
neuroscientist in michigan um
who distinct who came up with this
distinction between what he called
liking and wanting right and often those
things move together but it turns out
that in the brain
chemically they they don't right and so
you can see that if you go in and sort
of manipulate dopamine
and see what happens you know and so it
turns out that if you like let's take a
rat and you you give it a drug that kind
of you know depresses its dopamine
function
um it turns out that the rat doesn't
actually from what we can tell lose its
ability to
experience pleasure and we can tell that
by like you know they do research where
they video the face of the faces of rats
and like see whether they whether they
show these sort of like you know outward
signs of pleasure
um like you know
right exactly like you know like licking
their licking their fingers and all
these kind of things
um
and it turns out that you know rats
whose dopamine system has been depressed
don't
show any they basically still show all
the outward signs of pleasure what they
don't do is actually like go work to get
food so you can if you make it at all
difficult for them to to like you know
go get something they like they'll just
sort of they won't do it so they kind of
become little you know couch potato rats
um
and so so this has led to this idea that
you know dopamine is really important
not so much for
the the pleasurable aspects of reward
but sort of the the wanting what we call
the incentive aspects of reward um and
it you know sort of fits with this idea
that you know we know from from lots of
you know people talking about addiction
right that at some point addiction you
know we know dopamine plays a central
role in addiction um and you know when
somebody becomes addicted it's not as if
they're keep continuing to take the drug
to continue to get pleasure right what
they're usually doing is continue
discontinue take to the drug just to get
back to where they started um and uh and
part of that is driven by this you know
this sort of um
the the strong craving and incentive
that one's the kind of wanting that you
get from the changes in the dopamine
system that happen in addiction so about
addiction so is it is addiction
just a habit is there more to it than
that how do we think about that
um yeah this is a controversial topic
right now because you know many people
think of addiction as being about habits
but if you look at you know what look at
how you know what what happens in
addiction
you know we don't usually think of
habits as being really kind of like
flexible sorts of behaviors we think of
habits as being like you know the thing
that we automatically do in a situation
but if you look at the way that you know
that people who are addicted to drugs
go about trying to obtain drugs
they're really creative and sort of
flexible behaviors um that don't look
like habits and so one idea that's
developed
that's you know sort of related to ideas
that have come from uh fiery cushman
who's at harvard um and lee hogarth in
england has developed this idea that um
that it might be that the
what becomes habitual is just the goal
this the the goal of getting drugs
becomes the habit and um the the the
actual taking of the drug drug isn't
really a habit it's the the kind of the
getting of the the wanting of the drug
becomes the habit
complicated so so okay why are habits so
you use the word sticky a lot
yeah in your book right
why are habits sticky and what do you
mean by sticky
what i mean by sticky is is largely that
they they
they're really hard to get rid of like
you know they don't go away on their own
and even when you try to change them uh
it's very challenging and they tend to
come back
um and so why i mean there's there's
various ways to answer that question
right you know um
i think evolutionarily why we have
habits that are sticky is that you know
we we generally lived in during
evolution we lived in um
environments that you know that didn't
change anywhere near as fast as our
world changes now right um and so it
made sense for our brain to basically
learn how to do things and then just
kind of hold on to that right um
and
so that strategy
turns out to to work until it doesn't
and when it doesn't is when the world
changes or when you know things go from
being
uh you know adaptive to to non-adaptive
and particularly in the context of you
know the kinds of rewards that we
experience
in
the world today
um and the kind of you know incentives
that we experience like like drugs like
you know ultra processed hyperpalatable
foods like digital devices that provide
us lots of you know novel social
information all these things that we
think probably drive you know increase
dopamine release um
they make it particularly hard they make
it particularly easy to develop habits
and then those things can be
particularly hard to change um you know
so some of the ways in which
some of the things that happen in habits
that i think are particularly important
for
the stickiness
one is just the degree to which habits
become mindless right that you don't
you're completely unaware that you're
engaged in a habit and when you're
unaware of something it's very hard to
stop yourself from doing it right
and and getting insight into you know
getting insight into those habits is
challenging i tell a story in the book
about um
my wife and i were in new zealand about
a decade ago uh we're driving from
like christ church up to marlborough on
the on the south island through the
mountains really windy little road and
um it was really my first time they've
ever driven on the left side of the road
and we come up to this construction area
where they have it's like the lights
when they put you on one side of the
road they put us on the right side of
the road and you know drive for a couple
miles and the construction ends at some
point but i don't realize that it ends
so i'm just kind of driving along on the
right side of the road for some number
of miles until basically i come around a
corner and there's a car in my face
unfortunately we were going slow we
didn't hit anything but um but it's just
you know it speaks to the fact that even
though i was really intently trying to
drive on the left side of the road just
a little bit of distraction sort of just
turn you know
put me back in the habit mode um and you
know could have been really bad yeah
well good for you for trying i went to
south africa and i just decided not to
try right
um
so okay so habits you know we talked a
lot about bad habits but they're also
good habits right
so but it seems like good habits are
harder to create yeah then bad habits
are to you know to burn well i mean then
bad habits so
why would that be the case is that the
case first of all
and if so why would that be the case
i think it's pretty cle i mean
intuitively it's certainly the case um
and
you know there's some work it's
interesting you know people there's this
lore about you know habits taking 21
days to uh
to create which turns out to basically
be you know something made up by a guy
writing a pop psychology book isn't it
like ten thousand hours or something uh
that's something different that's
something different yeah yeah yeah
that's more like expertise yeah that's
like the far end of habits right gotta
go um
but it turns out that like you know some
recent work looked at like look at
people trying to develop barriers have
various quote-unquote good habits and
you know it
took anywhere from like you know what
two weeks to four months i think um so
you know there's a big range in kind of
how but clearly it's you know it can
take a long time to establish a good
habit and i think one of the reasons is
that you know the things that we call
bad habits are generally habits that are
driven by
sort of strong rewards right
um whereas um the things that we think
of as good habits are generally things
that we don't really want to do you know
be it flossing or going to the gym you
know
whatever that might be
um and
the problem is that we don't get when
you don't get any kind of you know
rewarding outcome you don't have
dopamine to help you establish
that habit you know through that the
kind of plasticity that i talked about
earlier and so you have to rely on other
mechanisms in particular you know you
have to rely on the prefrontal cortex
kind of driving you know having this
goal of oh hey i need to floss tonight
and to remember to floss
and
developing a habit through that type of
you know what you might call top-down
kind of control
um is just much harder um and it and
that's part of why it takes much longer
is because you don't have the the kind
of the support of the the dopamine
system
um i just want to say to the audience so
i'm in about 10 minutes i'll stop and
take questions so if you have questions
please put them into the q a um i will
read them uh so give us your name so we
can acknowledge you and uh
i still have a bunch of questions for
russ before we get there so
um all right so speaking about good
habits uh
this also gets to breaking bad habits
you talk about this new scientific
emphasis on behavior change
um you know and this has been something
you talk about the national institute of
health um sort of emphasizing behavior
change can you say a little bit more
about what that is yep and how it
relates to this idea of habits
yeah so
you know anybody who's ever tried to
make any kind of change in their life
you know especially sort of a healthy
change be it you know quitting smoking
or starting to exercise any of these
things you know we'll we'll one realize
how difficult behavior like changing
one's behavior is when we talk about
behavior change we're speaking very
broadly about you know the ability to to
behave differently in a way that is in
service of some kind of usually health
goal right um
and
one thing we know is that you know a
huge proportion of
health out of you know of bad health
outcomes
could be prevented by behavior change
you know smoking is by far the the top
one of those right if people could just
snap their finger and stop smoking
tomorrow you know so much uh
you know illness would be avoided in
terms of like cancer heart disease
chronic lung diseases um
and but it's hard right so a lot of the
research has shown that it actually
hasn't changed at all really
in the last like four decades that you
know if when people try to quit
something be it alcohol smoking drugs
uh you know about a third of them last a
year in terms of like how long they can
stay abstinent um and and like i said
that hasn't changed you know there's
been a ton of research but you know we
haven't really gotten better at helping
people figure out how to change their
behavior and so that's why the nih has
gotten really interested in this because
it it spans all the different classes of
diseases um
and um and it and we realized that it
could you know
the ability to easily change behavior
would be much more powerful than any
particular drug that anybody could
develop for disease
it makes a bit it makes a lot of sense
and it's kind of surprising that it's
sort of a new thing right that the
national institute of health is is
emphasizing um
all right so now let's get to this so i
will say in reading your book
you know the first part of it um you
know beautiful neuroscience going
through the details of what we know
about habits you know and linking in the
the working animals with you know not
non-human animals with
innovative techniques with what we know
in humans
really really great but that book is
about that part of your book is
more than three quarters of the book i
think right
because the second part of the book
is sort of you know the the big question
right um and and i just to give you
credit up front in the first chapter you
say
you know we still aren't quite there yet
but the second part of the book is what
do we do now like what if we have a
habit that we want to break how do we
you know what is the best science today
telling us um and i and
and you know i know it's frustrating
because that's that's everyone wants to
know that like what is the there is
there a magic bullet now and then i'm
going to ask you about you know
in the future later but go ahead
right right what are the the eight
simple
tricks to get rid of your habits right
and unfortunately there are no such
eight simple tricks and part of the you
know
one of the points i try to make right is
that you know changing behavior is hard
and um
that should it should lead us to be
empathetic for people who have trouble
changing their behavior right um it's
not as if they have poor willpower or
something like that it's really it's you
know it's fundamentally a really hard
thing um
and you know there's a lot of stuff
that's kind of presented you know on the
web in the press you know in terms of
like
methods that people suggest to work
that you know often aren't really well
supported by evidence and i talk about
some of those in the book there's also
some stuff that i think is you know
fairly well supported um and a lot of
that
has to do with
sort of things that you do before you
ever kind of get into the situation of
having to
like you know suppress a habit
um
you know because we know that like our
our ability to control our behavior once
we end up kind of in the heat of the
moment is just fundamentally
poor right our our prefrontal cortex is
just weak when it in when it comes up
against our the power of our habit
system um and so you know the things
that seem
the things that are well established are
particularly things like you know
planning ahead like there's this idea of
what are called implementation
intentions like you know
if i end up in a situation we'll say i'm
trying to you know to not smoke and i
have to go to a place where you know i'm
often tempted to smoke kind of walking
through in my head what exactly will i
do when that you know in order to avoid
the
the the habit getting triggered or if it
starts to get triggered how will i you
know kind of deal with that situation so
really like
planning ahead
um you know there's there's a lot of
other ideas that seem to have you know
some evidence behind them um another
another interesting one is you know
temptation bundling where you basically
you only allow yourself to do something
that you like to do but you know you
shouldn't do if you do it at the same
time as you're you know as you're doing
something good so you only let yourself
watch the the trashy tv show when you're
on the treadmill right
um there's there's a number of things
like that but the knicks so yeah
um but but yeah so i you know i talk
about a number of those things in the
book but none of them is a magic bullet
so okay so so what things don't work
what do people think what you know what
are the kinds of things you hear about
you know obviously breaking bad habits
is something that lots of people talk
about and there's lots of advice out
there what what doesn't work that people
think might work
um
yeah interesting so
i think that uh
well there's you know one of the things
that people have talked about a lot in
the last few years is this idea of sort
of nudges right of um kind of just
giving people little sort of pushes to
push them in the right direction or
maybe even like giving them a little
reward to help them go in the right
direction um and there's now a lot of
work that shows that you know if you um
for example you know there's this idea
um from from addiction where you can
actually like pay addicts not to take
the drugs right and that works really
well as long as you keep paying them
once you stop paying them they you know
the effects go away pretty quickly and
similar things have been seen with
exercise katie milkman and angela
duckworth did a really large study
that you know looked at the ability to
kind of nudge people to exercise and it
kind of worked as long as you were
nudging them but the the effects didn't
really last um
another you know another thing i talk
about in the book that's sort of
interesting but i think where the the
evidence is still
uh
not there is meditation
that you know meditation i think it's a
really interesting thing and it may well
have like you know really good effects
but the the science behind meditation is
um in terms of like you know especially
for things like changing habits is um is
pretty shaky right now
but but but it does have an effect on
stress which is something that you also
link to habits so that's true yeah
yeah so um so the
the interesting thing about stress is
that it you know impacts the ability of
our prefrontal cortex to function um amy
arnstein from yale has done really nice
work showing how exactly different
neurochemicals like dopamine and
noradrenaline which is the stress chem
stress neurochemical how they basically
degrade the ability of neurons in the
prefrontal cortex to kind of do their
thing
and that means that you know the ability
to control one's behavior that's what
the pre-formal cortex does for us that
becomes even weaker and so it's even
harder to kind of both you know work in
service of your goals and to sort of
resist any kind of you know temptation
that you need to resist yeah for me like
you know i'm trying to take off 10
pounds like when i'm stressed you know
i'm not worried about that so much um
okay so i want to um
so you so you you go through the science
of
you know what what has been shown to
really work
uh what doesn't really work there's uh
two other questions about so are there
particular types of people that are
better at like are some people just
better at you know sort of
dealing with their bad habits than
others i guess you know are there are
their personal are there you know
variabilities in their personality that
makes some people good at this like do
they have better willpower right yeah
yeah willpower is an interesting one
right i mean certainly there are people
you know some people have better what we
might call self-control than others
right and you know as a psychologist we
can give people questionnaires and ask
them questions like do you say things
that you later regret saying or do you
make impulse buys at the grocery store
and we see that some people
systematically
kind of behave in more of what we call
impulsive or less controlled ways right
and so there's this idea that that might
have something to do with our ability to
to break habits and that that focuses
around this idea of willpower right that
if we could just resist our habits
um that that would that's that's the key
right and it turns out that some recent
research suggests that that might be the
wrong way to that might not actually be
what willpower is all about um so
wilhelm hoffman and his colleagues did
this interesting study a while ago they
gave people devices
um they were blackberries actually
because this was like 10 years ago and
they would buzz at them you know a few
times a day and they would basically say
have you experienced a desire in the
last 30 minutes
and then if they said yes did you try to
resist the desire and if they said yes
then
were you successful in resisting the
desire
and then
these people also filled out a bunch of
those questionnaires where you you know
see who claims to have high self-control
and who doesn't so you would if you know
if willpower was really about like
resisting urges then you would think
that the people with good self-control
would be going through the world
resisting the urges more effectively
but that's not actually what they found
it turns out the people with high
willpower and low power low willpower
basically claim to resist their urges
equally often the big difference was
that the people who have good
self-control had fewer urges in the
first place
um and it's it's relevant to some work
that um that angela duckworth has done
showing that basically people with good
self-control seem to be particularly
good at developing good habits right and
probably like you know stay you know
either like never developing the bad
habits or kind of you know being able to
avoid the temptation in the first place
got it okay so so
in the last chapter of your book
you talk about um this what you call
hacking right these and these are sort
of
new neuroscientific insights that might
be relevant to
um you know behavior change and changing
habits in the future
so
of all of the ones that you mentioned
which one do you think is most promising
at this particular point in time like
which one would you had to imagine you
know
which one might actually break through
and work
interesting
um yeah so
let me just say what the menu is right i
mean the menu is really um the menu is
really drugs that can erase memories
right um or particular
kind of behavioral techniques that can
help uh you know some of the stuff that
you've worked on that can help try to
erase memories um or
stimulation of the brain using this
stuff we call optogenetics right which
basically uses light to control the
activity of neurons
um
that um that is certainly more so you
know optogenetics is almost certainly
the most precise of any of those
mechanisms i think um
the challenge there is going to be
actually getting optogenetics into
humans because it would it would require
brain surgery and it would require gene
therapy to put you know the the ion
channels into your neurons using viruses
yeah it's a lot scary yeah um so i think
actually that in terms of like something
that's
closest to being like really applicable
in the world
i think actually the kind of you know
techniques that you've worked with like
you know looking at what we call
reconsolidation
which where you basically like you know
ex kind of
cause a memory to be reactivated and
then use what we know about
memories to basically somehow disrupt
that memory because because we've
learned through you know
work from from a lot of people in the
last couple of decades that memories
become unstable whenever you retrieve
them and you can actually kind of
cause them to be degraded um
you know i think that that technique
still isn't ready for prime time either
but i think it it's it's certainly the
it's the least
it's the least science fictiony of all
of them yeah and it's also the least you
know invasive but at the same time but
but you know having worked in this area
i agree with you i think we
you know there's several types of memory
how do you target the right one how do
we know a memory is active in the human
brain without any you know sort of
technique to really look in the human
brain that tells us exactly the time
point and what's the right intervention
or questions but i but you know i would
be excited personally because i'm
invested in that uh that research um
okay so i have just two more questions
for you um
so first one what is your worst habit
what is my worst habit
um i haven't you changed it yet can i go
get my wife and ask
her uh
yeah it's interesting um
you know probably um
you know okay i've actually been pretty
good at stopping getting rid of sweets
you know i definitely have not gotten
rid of wine and covet has not helped
with that
um
so you know my bad habit is probably
drinking more wine than i should um and
uh and it's you know it's
i know all the things one should do and
i'm you know i know sometimes successful
when i decide hey i shouldn't you know
shouldn't drink as much this week i'm
successful doing that um but um but it's
it's equal you know my all my knowledge
about how the habit system works is not
endowed me with any sort of special
powers when it comes to breaking out of
this
um well you know you didn't tell us a
really bad one so maybe we'll follow up
afterwards um
but uh so okay last question i have and
then we'll go to the to the um
to the uh
the attendees so imagine it's 20 45
right so 25 years for 2046 sorry 25
years from now
do you think
the science of behavior change you know
where we try to break these bad habits
because they're bad for our health right
because they're related to things like
cancer and heart disease and other
things that you know can kill us do you
think we would have made like a lot of
significant progress in that time are
you optimistic is just what i'm asking
you about you know the the science
evolving in such a way that it does
become practical for people in their
everyday lives
i i think i am um in part because i
think there's an ongoing change in how
people are starting to
think about studying these things i
think that as i talk about in the book
the approach that's been used to try to
study behavior change for the last you
know four or five decades hasn't really
tried to get at
the mechanisms of behavior change and
now people are thinking a lot more about
that kind of driven by work of some
people at the national institutes of
health um in the science of behavior
change program so i think that that's
gonna you know in the same way that like
moving towards trying to understand the
molecular mechanisms of cancer brought
about you know in the last
few years these new treatments that can
much more
you know at least occasionally much more
effectively and a much more targeted way
treat specific cancers based on the
exact biology of the cancer i think the
idea is we you know we could have the
same kind of progress in understanding
behavior change
i hope so i i agree with you i think
we're getting there and i think you know
the fact that
it's it's odd that it took so long to
really recognize the importance of this
um as a major health uh you know
intervention um but you know the the
obviously uh it is a major health
intervention and i'm glad we're starting
to focus on it all right so i'm going to
go to some of the questions now um from
the attendees so the first is from amit
solenke
is there a difference in the stickiness
of a good versus a bad habit
uh interesting yeah um
i don't know of research on this i mean
intuitively certainly there is and i
think that the one
the so you know what we know about
you know the stickiness of habits comes
in part because like any time the first
like the first thing that one learns in
a particular situation
often becomes like the default behavior
um and um the you know in general bad
habits aren't going to be the sorry good
habits aren't going to be the first
thing that you learned in the situation
they become kind of an add-on so they
they generally become both
much more difficult to create and much
less likely to sort of you know come
back and to stick around
um
all right so mark posado
do emotions or moods positive or
negative become habits that might be
changed and how and which brain network
does that involve yeah that's an
interesting question so i think you know
i i think emotions moods thoughts
all these things can become habits just
like behaviors can
um and so i you know i guess i
i think they they probably rely on
different brain systems you know i mean
you've you've done a lot of work around
you know one particular emotion fear
right um and the brain systems that are
kind of involved in that becoming
conditioned and ultimately becoming a
habit so i think that there certainly
are and i don't i don't actually know
what the systems would be for sort of
the like moods um
you know but um
you know emotion is kind of a far-flung
thing in the brain right um but but
certainly it is the case that you know
and thoughts as well like and i think
you know when we think about like
obsessive-compulsive disorder is like
the extreme version of thoughts becoming
habits so they're just automatically
continually you know sort of uh
retrieved yeah i mean i also i often
wonder you know to what extent that you
know there's one finding out there that
which is a great for those of us who are
getting older right that the older you
get the more positive outlook you have
but you know and that's partially due to
just how you interpret you know the
things that they like is the glass half
full or half empty and i wonder that
just can become a habit for people if
you do it a lot um
okay so this is one this is an anonymous
attendee but this question is very near
and dear to my heart
um because i'm actually going through
the same thing what is a winning
strategy to create a positive habit for
successfully getting one's children to
practice piano or anything they don't
see as fun
for the long term they seem to love it
once they can perform a piece but the
fight
but but fight the learning process and
complain about having to practice it's a
constant struggle
the short answer is is i have no idea
i started a reward box things at my
house you get a dollar every time you
practice but you know right right no i
think that actually you know well i
think you know the right the the
question is how do you make them
motivated to do it on their own how do
you make it fun enough and rewards
obviously could play a role in that and
there there's a another interesting
question buried in there about like you
know
where does the reward from like self
like success that something like you
know playing a piano piece come from
something that i've thought about a lot
but i don't think there's really any
science on kind of the reward of success
it's an interesting question
um it is a good question yeah um and i
think if you can come up with a great
answer i'll you know i'd like to know um
all right so this is from william brewer
says hi russ bill brewer here
um
um absent-mindedness plan slips seem to
fit nicely into your approach example
a professor goes into his bedroom to
change into formal clothes for a concert
his wife comes in and finds him in his
pajamas do you have an account
yeah um i think i talk a bit about these
sort of action slips in the book
and i think that it's a it's a great
example of the the power of these kind
of extended routines right that if you
have a
the the thing that becomes really
difficult um in like you know in
breaking habits is like once you've
started the routine
you you know you your your mind it
becomes mindless as i'm talking about
before we've all had this experience
right of like needing to stop somewhere
on the way home
getting home and realizing that we
forgot to stop at that place right
because the the root of getting home has
just become such a such an automatic
sort of habitual thing um and there's
there's lots of interesting neuroscience
on this you know ann graybiel and her
colleagues at mit have done great stuff
showing like you and rats exactly how
the activity in the basic i think it
goes from being like continuous through
the whole behavior to like starting at
the beginning and then basically going
away until they're done doing their
whole routine um and so i think that
there's a there's a good explanation for
that in terms of like the the kind of
chunking together of a whole bunch of
behaviors into one big routine that
becomes automatic as a whole
so um next question is from felix bergel
i i actually want to say felix i think
the whole book is about this this
question but i'll let russ take a step a
short stab at it so it says hello thank
you very much for such interesting
conversation my question
are there biological or physiological
obstacles to breaking habits
i mean i think that there yeah there's a
so there's a there's a number of ways to
to kind of think about that um one is
simply the you know as i mentioned the
the relative fragility of the prefrontal
cortex right when we whenever we need to
exert control
we have to rely on the prefrontal cortex
and we know that it's easily disrupted
by by stress
um by lack of sleep by you know lots of
different things um and so
um
that's certainly probably the biggest
one um and then the i think the other
you know the other physiological
obstacle if you think about as an
obstacle it's really the degree to which
you know we live now in a
in an environment that stimulates us in
ways that our dopamine system and the
rest of our brain weren't evolved to
deal with right so we're so you know
if you go take a lot of different drugs
like cocaine or methamphetamine they
kind of directly turn on your dopamine
system right or like cause dopamine to
hang around but that's so far outside of
our evolutionary experience that we're
just not equipped to deal with those
sorts of things
so nancy lyons asks a very relevant
question how do you explain a failure to
wear masks or get a vaccine in terms of
habits when the downside is so clear
yeah this is really interesting and i
think actually it points to
something that that i don't really
address at all in the book except at the
very end when i talk about you know
climate change and covet um and um but
that has to do with like another layer
of like behavior change right which is
which has to do with kind of mindsets
and beliefs and ideologies right so in
some ways you know
like
if you don't believe you need to change
your behavior then there's no need to
right back when people thought smoking
was healthy there was no need to stop
smoking um
and so um so i think it's
this is highlighted i think both in the
context of you know i think the the
whole like you know anti-mask
uh
[Music]
thing is is one version of this the kind
of you know opposition to
um to changes relevant to to you know
societal change relevant to climate
change is another that um that
ultimately you know before for any kind
of change to happen
there has to be a a mindset or a belief
that drives that change and and they can
be really powerful right it's like i you
know about a decade ago i made a big
change in my diet i had been like
vegetarian high carb for a long time
wasn't feeling particularly healthy and
decided to basically change my diet to
really cut out sweets become like a
meat-eating low-carb nut and and it
worked but it really you know to make it
work because i had like sugar cravings
like crazy right but to make it work the
thing that made it work was having this
mindset of like oh this is this is the
way i have to eat if i want to be
healthy right and that translates then
into like you know the motivation to do
the things that you think you need to do
but ultimately it has to come from that
high level belief or mindset and so
that's this i think this whole societal
moment is kind of highlighting the
importance of that
so um so this gets back to oh now i'm
going to go back to another question
which was uh
so this was a from a meet uh solanki
again this relates this so what what
world does human intent play in the
creation of sustenance and getting rid
of habits
human intent yeah
it's interesting well
i guess the first you know question is
like what what role does an intent play
in our behavior like everybody thinks
that you know when they go do things in
the world they're doing them
because they they want to do them right
or they intend to do them um you know
wendy wood and her colleagues did some
work a while ago basically trying to
quantify like you know
when when people do things are they
really doing them because they want to
do them are they doing them because
they've done them before and it turned
out that a lot of behavior can be
accounted for simply by the fact that
it's a habit that is something that's
the thing you've done previously in the
same situation so the first thing is
just to realize that you know that the
idea that everything we do it comes from
an intention
is is clearly you know not the right way
to think about human behavior much of
what we do has to do with habit
um and i think the you know on the flip
side the the stuff that i talked about
in terms of like implementation
intentions right
um where you
think about what will i do in this
particular situation that turns out to
be a a well-established you know method
or at least there's there's evidence for
it from from controlled trials
suggesting that it can actually help
people change their behavior um so
that's a place where you know used in
the right way
and i hope this is like i hope i'm
getting at the the questioner's uh
intent here if you will um but i think
that that's a place where like you know
intention can be used in the right way
to actually help behavior change work
so um nikhil vas asks what is the effect
of a companion for example a spouse and
breaking your making habits
it's like an external prefrontal cortex
yeah no i think it well one it so you
know one of the really hard parts about
breaking habits is like realizing that
you're doing the thing right um kind of
getting insight into you know it's like
like i used to bite my fingernails um
and um i did i didn't really realize i
was biting
my fingernails i just did it right um
and so having a spouse who
is you know saying hey will you stop
doing that right
um it is it helps you gain insight into
the um the frequency with which you do
it the situations in which you do it and
it helps you give it helps give you
motivation right i never had motivation
to not bite my fingernails but then when
it when i realized that it annoyed my
wife so much that gave me motivation to
actually make that change so i think
between the the kind of insight and the
motivation those are both
aspects where like other people in your
life can actually help including spouses
can help drive that
i love the spouse's your your external
prefrontal cortex remember that um
all right so this is kind of a tough
question um but it's from dh it says
rush a generalization of what you're
saying diminishes some of what's
popularly
believed about free will free choice and
free will
do you believe in free will
do i have to answer that question no you
do not have to answer that no i you know
i i i think i think i have free will um
i don't you know the these are the kinds
of questions that i try not to spend
much time thinking about just because i
don't know that they're answerable um
that i think they're interesting and i
like to occasionally read you know
philosophers talk about them i think i i
think when i make choices that i i can
do things on my free will but i don't
know how to scientifically
uh establish that well clearly the
notion that you know you're doing you
know sometimes you do
you continue in habits even
when you know it's not your intention
right it speaks to that it doesn't mean
that there isn't free will it just means
that you know
we're not always you know doing you know
acting according to our conscious
attentions right exactly i certainly
believe you know there's this idea i
think it comes from vs ramachandran a
free won't right and i certainly believe
that i have the ability to not do
something that i was going to do
um
by by force of will whatever that is
so i don't know if you if you know
anything about it but greg burke asks is
there a role for hypnosis and altering
habits uh interesting question i don't
know anything about uh evidence for or
against that
okay
um
so maybe we'll take two more so um
so david vosik says hi russ thank you
for a great talk
given habits developed to establish
long-term goals or to claim implicit or
indirect rewards
would you recommend a way to bring
rewards closer to the present
or to make or more explicit when when
starting to develop a new good habit so
i mean i think i think this builds on
like this right this idea that you
talked about for the good habits
there's not really a reward right yeah
that's interesting and you know one of
the um
thanks david that's a great question um
one of the things that we it's exactly
right right that why do i floss at night
um it's because i'm i'm doing that in
service of like a reward that isn't
going to come for years down the road
right like my you know not getting gum
disease um or months what some point
down the road right and that's of one of
the things we know about
future rewards is that they're much more
um
we our mind treats them as much more
abstract than immediate rewards like an
immediate reward is like something like
it's tangible right uh of the reward the
long-term reward of not getting gum
disease is like really abstract right
and so one of the things people thought
about is like you know there's this
whole idea of like having like thinking
about episodes in the future right
episodic future thinking to like bring
make things in the future more immediate
um
the evidence on that i think isn't you
know really great yet uh certainly in
the context of behavior change i haven't
seen any sort of you know established
evidence but that's that's one idea
about how to potentially make those
kind of longer-term rewards of
quote-unquote good habits more salient
in the short term
so okay last question i'll take um and
i'm gonna just sort of add something to
the end of this question because i think
it's related uh is by gwen spieth
um it says how do you move from having
an external prefrontal cortex to being
motivated on your own and she's talking
here about young adults sort of becoming
independent of their parents and their
own sort of healthy self-care
so i i was hoping you'd also say a
little bit about you know adolescence
and development and yeah
habits yeah i mean i think you know
there's a lot of interesting ideas about
what what's happening
during development right and we know the
one thing we certainly know is that the
prefrontal cortex develops relatively
late compared to the rest of the brain
and there's at least some evidence to
suggest that the reward systems develop
relatively early right compared to the
prefrontal cortex and that there's been
claims that that sort of mismatch
between like you know the reward systems
turning up early and the prefrontal
cortex not turning until you're 20 might
relate to some of the very impulsive
behavior that we see in uh in
adolescence
um
you know how
the question of you know how to optimize
that is a good one and i don't think
anybody really knows the answer to that
um
other than providing you know one of the
things that we know is really powerful
in adolescence is uh social influence
right that you know adolescents are
particularly willing to like
take risks and do impulsive things in a
context of you know of kind of peer
pressure um and so you know figuring out
how to
kind of you know organize things
socially so that kids end up in
situations now the problem is right we
can't choose our kid our kids friends
right um but but i think you know it's
kind of understanding that and and maybe
trying to highlight the degree to which
you know peer pressure is a really
powerful influence might be one way to
think about that
great so um before we close do you have
anything else you want to uh say about
habits of your book i mean i i i thought
it was terrific i really enjoyed it and
like i said i think for
for people that really want to
understand the neuroscience i think it's
one of the you know in terms of you know
what's happening in the brain with
habits what's happening in the brain
when you try to stop habitual behaviors
uh and where we could potentially go in
the future
you know i think it was it was
incredible just reading like the the
level the ease with which you were able
to convey
the uh the complicated science behind
habits anything you want to say before
we close today no well thanks liz i mean
i i really appreciate that and that's
because that's exactly what i tried to
do and i think that you know i think our
discussion has done a good job of
highlighting like all the different
things that i talk about in the book so
yeah
well cool i can't wait to see what
happens in uh in
201 2046.
right
we'll still be around
well thank you tremendously both of you
for this fascinating discussion and i
also want to thank everyone who joined
us this evening we had so many
thoughtful questions in the chat tonight
um if anyone would like to learn more
copies of hard to break our for sale on
harvard.com via the links that i have
been putting in the chat um so on behalf
of harvard bookstore the harvard
division of science and the harvard
library have a good evening everyone
keep reading and please please be well
thank you
here's a look now at some of the
best-selling non-fiction books according
to the ivy book shop in baltimore